what uh well first let me ask you this
do you think trump's going to find a way
to
stay in the presidency i mean i think
the odds are probably like what we were
talking about before when you look
because we're biggest betting odds a lot
of people will say to me they go
80 like he's got he's coming back like
you don't even know
and i go if that's the case why don't
you mortgage your house
and bet it because you've got the inside
scoop and you'll make a million dollars
right you obviously know right so i mean
i think it's probably
close to what those odds are i mean it
would be very difficult to
turn three things i think that's those
are odds based on what people
uh those are the odds based on what
people think well i don't know
so this is the only odds we have but
yeah we have that doesn't mean anything
it just means we have election betting
odds that
have trump at 10.5 percent to be the
next president that's higher than
everyone and predicted has him at 13
cents a share
to win the electoral college that's a
money bet
man but winning the electoral college
that's that's not him becoming the
president like he could become president
a lot of ways winning the electoral
college means overturning these states
and then trump
gaining those votes from buying so
there's less of a chance of that way
less of a chance
yeah trump could become president
through like uh the lights go off and
then he comes out and ddt's joe biden
right right right off the ladder that's
i've seen it i know i've seen that
happen before
it could be uh uh something happens to
joe biden maybe it could be a contingent
election where the house delegates pick
them it's not through the electoral
college
and they're saying 13 cents a share so
here's what i'm telling people okay
if you really think they're going to
release the kraken and they've got all
this evidence and it's coming and
trump's going to win
it's like you just said it mortgage your
house put all that money down if you
really believe i don't i don't actually
think people should do that
that's because deep down you probably
think that they're gonna lose their
house oh yeah yeah they're gonna lose
so look i'll tell you this i remember in
2016 when
people were like bet on trump i'm gonna
bet on trump and the odds were around
the same thing
i know people who put down 100 bucks
because it was a value bet meaning
if i lose 100 bucks whatever i could win
a thousand but that also
this idea that you're going to lose 100
bucks because you might want a thousand
it means you think you might win it
means you think trump could do it
if someone came to you and said here's a
bet 100
guarantee you lose all your money but
if you do win which you can't you'll get
a thousand bucks people are gonna be
like no what what do you mean
right so they actually do think trump
but also if you bid a hundred bucks like
i'll i'll put a
hundred to five hundred dollars down
just straight up because it's funny
but you're not gonna i'm not gonna drop
five hundred bucks like i did
on this election i i bet yeah i bet uh
500 on trump and i was like i didn't
think well you didn't lose it yet
right just i just thought it would be
funny because i'm like
i knew i was doing all these like
election shows that night and i go if
people are melting down and i just want
a thousand bucks
i'm like that's really yeah it'll be
hilarious which almost happened but then
but i was just straight up because i
thought it was funny like i didn't carry
either way what if
you know on election night 2016 we had
the slow motion breakdown
as the state started coming in one by
one for trump trump's winning
and then the left slowly started losing
their mind more and more it's like that
famous young turks video where he's like
we can still do it if we get wisconsin
then it's like wisconsin trump goes
what if we're seeing that but like times
100
where and and i don't even i don't i do
not think the odds of this
happening are 10 i think it's like .001
like really slim but could you imagine
what it would be like if they're all
dancing in the street and stomping on
cheetos bags and they're
celebrating pulling off their masks and
chugging
champagne and handing it to each other
and then a week later
one of the one of the states is refusing
turns orange
this guy but like i'm imagining you know
so we're still we're still about a month
out from the electoral college
certification a lot can happen
so what happens like next week there's
some suit and it's like
philadelphia flips you know from some
you know giuliani's suit wins
and then the left goes okay well i mean
joe biden still won
we're celebrating good times you know
and then a week and a half later and
then it's like arizona and then trump
somehow pulls it off and it's this month
long
it was one day in 2016 it's a one month
long slow drawn out process of trump
flipping things and winning i think a
lot of these people would be
honestly happy about it totally you know
there's a whole industry
you know built around this stuff when i
was even the day that he won like
you know that a lot of people in these
like activist organizations were like
that night
looking at their baton and having like a
will i won't die moment
you know what i mean it's just like
watching like it's still there's
you know trump might win so you're
saying there's a chance they got the
molotov cocktails
they can't bring themselves to throw out
the molotov cocktail because it just
might happen
jeff zucker's over at cnn and he goes
what have i done
he's gonna lose all the money well
they're dude they're going to sell cnn
there's there's rumors that uh 18 i
heard they're going to do it to tell a
tune
that's what i heard really yeah no
that's what i heard i definitely heard
that
a canadian art cartoon network
people are saying trump might buy it but
i think that's just wishful thinking
could you imagine how hilarious it would
be if trump buys cnn
they'd block that sale though yeah they
wouldn't let it happen but but listen
listen
if so at t's like sale yeah well no
they're in the hole att doesn't care
about this stuff
these massive corporations are like dude
give me money they're not i'm sure
deep down they're like i don't care and
then trump bought cnn i hope breitbart
rises the capital to buy sienna
all right but no no here's the problem
cnn is worth nothing now
that's why they need to sell it cnn was
going down the tubes a long time ago and
then trump showed up
and they started blasting trump rallies
on tv non-stop and it helped him get
elected
but they were making money off of it the
ratings were going up by showing trump
so the people wanted
they wanted the orange man hey dude i've
i've been agreeing with you on
we've been talking about this for a
while but i'm like dude when trump got
voted out of office a lot of people's
entire comedy career just got voted out
of office
well so so you did a bit you had the
sketch where it's like a newsroom
on election night yeah and they all
cheer like yeah bite in harris
and then it's like a month later and
they're all sweating and like what do we
write about
there's nothing to write about it's over
so and i was watching i went to um
like union square the day after so they
had their big party in brooklyn and
everyone's happy i went it was pretty
fun
and uh did you get to stop by cheetos
did you did you i got this
i know i went i was uh i was with like a
bunch of friends and we kept like doing
jokes to each other like i would yell me
and danny were like
kind of weird you being here after
voting for trump no
loudly in front of all the broken people
like i kept saying
i kept trying to start a locker up chant
and then blame it on danny gosh
were you actually yelling yeah dude
nobody would join in
no obviously not but i was also like i'd
run out of the way and pretend it was i
was just kidding around
but so the next day after everyone you
know had their fun i went to the i was
just filming in union square the next
day and this is where they protest
they've been doing a protest against
trump
every saturday for the last eight months
a
impeachment you know like get him out of
the office right so i go and like mess
with him a lot of times but
the day after the day after he won they
were all still there and they were like
this is just the beginning joe biden is
still complicit in islamophobia
transphobia you know white supremacy
like they didn't even take the day off
they didn't even take one day off it's
not gonna work
so they were right back in it but you
could tell the enthusiasm everyone
walking by was like
all right dude like it's over we don't
need
trump yeah the media companies need him
there there is going to be right now
they're probably all sitting down doing
some kind of like prayer circle saying
like that trump win
and then they're like no one can know we
want trump to win but if he doesn't win
we're all going to lose our jobs
there's been some flailing articles you
know oh dude we got one we got
there he's just yeah just
if you want to talk about scraping the
bottom of the barrel
so hard baby they're pulling out wood
chips
i give you the daily mail
ivanka trump quote blamed a fart on her
classmate when she was a bratty teenager
to be fair she did do that to me and i
needed to write that article to get
something off my chest it's all your
fault
this is not an exaggeration they
actually wrote an article about ivanka
trump
23 years ago or something farting and
then saying
it was you like that's the news
okay it it is the daily mail okay we
gotta give them a little benefit of the
doubt because it is the daily mail it's
not
just the daily mail it's a bunch of
other outlets who all wrote the same
dude the new york times yesterday
i'm not even it was it was actually not
the daily mail that that
initially wrote this story okay we got
it from yesterday
daily news former ivanka trump bff
remembers a fart blaming elitist for the
creepy dead
new york times wrote an article that
said in college trump took an upper
decker
oh my gosh are you serious oh my gosh
oh ryan do you wanna you know do people
know what an upper decker is
john took an upper decker in the girl's
bathroom
and it was a school he didn't even go to
i knew it wow
oh no when you take the uh the top off
the toilet the lid off the toilet and
you sit on top of it
so that when they flush it i got it yeah
upper
top shelf in it right yeah back in
chicago that was like you know top shelf
like liquor you know what i mean like
you know hooking up yeah top shelves
pretty you're not gonna want to vomit
well this is what what college age
people do for some reason i was just
joking
so anyway what's the thing when you
uh the oh yeah the ivanka uh trump dutch
oven someone oh my god
no it should be this is this is a
preview of what's up baron
trump when he was three
we are in the golden period right now
probably you should all if you if you if
you like
excitement you should be cherishing
every moment of this period now until
january 20th
i don't know what's going to happen
after january 20th maybe it's trump
maybe it's not if it's not trump
i don't think it's all gonna go back to
normal like what normal is supposed to
be things have been crazy since
before 2016 and they're getting crazier
and crazier so i imagine they'll be
getting a bit crazy but right now
donald trump according to the mainstream
media is out
so what do they write about it's it's it
you did it guys what's the protest
what's this so basically well no so they
have no choice
they still have to write about trump
because it's that golden goose but they
are squeezing
they're strangling the goose shaking as
hard as possible to get an egg out
and like little little like like uh
golden dingleberries are falling out
and they're getting the story like
ivanka trump farting and this is where
they have to write about trump somehow
and the only thing they could find
is this after trump is gone
they're gonna be writing stories about
trump and it's gonna be
like even worse yeah it's gonna be
darker yeah so
trump didn't uh lock himself in the
white house but he almost did
he almost did he thought about what
they're gonna do they're gonna be like
it's now been one month since donald
trump has left the white house
here's what things would be like if he
didn't no joke no joke
i bet you they'll write that article
yeah well that's what i predicted i was
saying in the articles like kamala
harris looked nice
you know stuff like that yeah it reminds
me of uh the family guy joke where the
news is like
you know plane crashed into a school
like here's what it would have been like
if another like the plane didn't crash
into school but here's what it would
have looked like if it did and then they
show it anyway because like
they need something to talk about do you
remember when caitlyn collins was like
trump has been silent for three days and
i was like
is this is this news i'm sorry i missed
it yeah
what the heck what the heck's going on
about it thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you